I'll never forget coming home from
school
popping this into the GameCube for the
first time on my old CRT television
and just being absolutely Blown Away
looks so good that's probably my
favorite version of samus's suit as well
yes
so good man
so many little effects
that just really added up over time
though and through the course of the
game I mean watch here's one right here
when you get close all right so first
boss fight of the game speaking of like
just great nods though they have where
you can actually pull out a GameCube
controller
you can plug in the GameCube controller
and it will still work all these years
later if you've played a Metroid game
before
you know what time it is it's time for
us to evacuate